πρέπει αποοϊδεύσεις όλα ν αυτό να εκό μος εψήφυση ναι μεγάλη ευθύνη το μεγάλο ποτο
δεν είναι εφυσυχασμοσε αντιθέτος για με ένα ι χειρότερο πράγα μου πρέε πει κάποιος είνι
ότι μετάκι μος αποσεψύφηση για μέν είαι το χειρόότε ρο πράγμα ο π ραι οπι
κάποιο έτυχ να γίνει αυτό ταξή σίγουρα ετυχε αλλά για τους λόγους που έτυχε δεν
νιοθβασχία τώρα μηνα εξυπηρτησείς κάποια προσωπικά θέματα η κάποια θέματα που απρόσεται γίνουνται και σε
λικρινίς δεν θερο τι εγκακόν αλλά να βρουν ενα άνθρωπος τω έναάνθρωπος το δρόμο κια
να μου πει χωρί ότι μετάιωσ πόσε ψύφησα αυτό γιαμένα είναι το χειρότρον πράκα έτσι
η θεωρώ ότι είναι α από τα γίνητραμο ότι σε καμια πρέπει ο τ δε
θέλω να νιώσο αυτό το πράγμα να πει κάποιο ότι νέ μετάνιμος απο εψήφυση τώρα
να ανέργω στη λέμες στη λάρνα γαση χωρίς που τα είνα γίναι μως τα γεεθύνι
της άρτας ήταν το λιμάνι και η μαρίνα ξεκίνησε σταμάτηση είναι νές προσφορές θα βρεθίληση
σε αυτόν το θέμα ταξιαυτό που θέλωυ να πω ότι αυτή την φρέπαμε ότι δεν
πρέπει α περιμένουμε των μεσία νεπενδητή πρ πρέει κάποια έργα να τα ξεκινήσουμε ναιεμείς ήτυη
και με το κράτους δηλαδ αυτό είη φράνα δεν μπορώ να πάνα αντικρίσουμα τον λαρνακια
για το πούμε θα κάπουμε μελέτη και θα βρούμε επενδητ αυτό έχει ικοση χρόνια από
α ποχει παντόσ ο πρόεδρος σήμερα πγάμνουμε τον γύρισμαείχε κάποιες ακαι αφε προσπαθεια πρέπει να
γίνει δεν θέλουν πό ότι δεν πρέει να γίνι προσπαθείαπρέπει να γίνει προσπαθει να βρύμε
ένα νέον είτα επενδητίνηται αυτός είναι ιδιότης είτα το κράτος σε κάποιος τομες αλλά αυτό
που που το οποίος συζητήσαμε έντωνα με το υπουρκώ μεταφορών καιθεωρώ ότι πρέπει ναλίξει σύντομα
είναι ότι πρέπει να πλέγουν ολαρνακ να δι έργα στο λιμένι μου μαρίνα και είναι
υτί ωσοστόχος και προσπάθεια μας χωρίς α άλη ν καθυστήρηση περιμένουμε τη λοπίση του προδρου
για ένα ποσό γο τα τριάτα εκατομήρια τεναδύο κατομύρια με αυτό τα ποσό μπορεί να
γίνει κάτι πολύ όριον ως πρώτο βήμα εκεί στην περοχή να γίνει να ανοπιθεί η
πλατεία εμυρώπηση η φινικούδες μας δεί με το χώρουν τις μαρίνας να είναι ς νας
ο ωένας οραίος χώρος μεση είνι δριακόν κέντρο με κάποιους χώρους τους οποίους στα χαίρεται
ο ραρνακές μέ να εξιτοργύρι αμόρφωση πάρκα κύπους ως πρώτο βήμα για την περαιτέρο επένδυση
της μαρίνας